democratic debate cocktails first up the
Hillary Clinton start with a glass of
champagne and add a splash of something
that's like southern comfort but isn't
the real thing then add some bitters any
flavor will do as long as it's aged best
would be bitters from 2008 if the press
is attending extend an olive branch into
the drink and then rescind it garnish
with some sour grapes and serve super
cold while trying to look warm next the
Bernie Sanders this drink is a classic
white russian with a few new wrinkles to
make it go down easier fill the glass
look plenty of other people's money the
drink just doesn't work without it
finished with a splash of our
forefathers tears and make sure to
equally distribute tiny portions to
everyone I could show you how to make a
lincoln Chafee or a Jim Webb or martin
O'Malley but let's be honest nobody's
going to drink those and while it may be
too early just in case here's the Joe
Biden just reach into the fridge without
looking and put whatever you grabbed
into the glass it may sound stupid but
people will know that you mean well and
they may even find it endearing in a
pinch you can just take someone else's
cocktail and claim it as your own now
you're ready for the debate so kick back
relax and enjoy what you've created
America